93هم الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2024
امر فتح باب النقاش حول كفائهم لقياده دفه
البلاد وحكم الدوله العظمى في العالم
الذين يشعرون ان هناك ميزانا للحكم للقاده
واخر للشخص اذا فعل نفس الشيء وان قادتنا
لديه مجموعه مختلفه من القواعد عن الشخص
العادي
الرئيس ادعاء انه لم يكن على علم بتلك
الوثائق وان البيت الابيض تعاون مع وزاره
العدل وسلم الوثائق 20 بمجرد العثور عليها
بينما ترم راى ان ملاحقه سياسيه نسجت
خطوطها في وزاره العدل وصلت الى حد مداهمه
منتجعه ومصادره مئات الوثائق بينما نائب
الرئيس السابق
اعلن عن تسليم الوثائق للمحفوظات الوطنيه
لكننا فقدان الشفافيه والمصداقيه والتستر
والاهمال اتهامات تلاحق الثلاثه بينما ترم
يواجه تحقيق القضائيا رسميا قد يؤدي الى
تجربه
انفسهم في مواجهه قانونيه وحتى ان تم
التهامهم بارتكاب جريمه هذا لا يمنع
قانونيا اي شخص من الترشح المنصب بموجب
القانون الامريكي لدافع ان المشكله ليست
قانونيه بل سياسيه لكن يبدو ان استطلاعات
الراي تشير الى ان الامريكيين عموما يرون
الفرق بين وضع ترامب ووضع بايدينا الان
اعتقد ان وضع بيضا ووضع بينس متشابهه لجدا
ازمه الوثائق الستلاحق بيضا وترامب
عندما يعلن الترشح رسميا
وستسمح لمرشحين اخرين بالنيل من مصداقيتهم
حتى لو نجوا من ملاحقه قضائيه
ممثلوا الرؤساء السابقين كلينتون جورج بوش
الاب والابن والرئيس اوباما قالوا بانهم
قاموا بتسليم كل الوثائق السريه التي كانت
بحوزتهم الى مكتب السجلات الوطنيه والرئيس
كارتر قال بانه لا يملك اي من الوثائق
السريه الكونجرس الان يبحث في اليه لمنع
الرؤساء والوزراء السابقين من الاحتفاظ
بوثائق قد تضر بالامن الوطني الامريكي
ناديه البلبيسي العربي